-Guys, we have
exactly 11 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 11 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a stupendous Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
cabinet.
Now since there are
11 shows left,
let's open door number 11!
I'll let you do it.
Okay. Oh, my!
Now, come on!
♪♪
Let's see what it is.
Oh, my goodness.
Sure, sure, yeah.
That is un-- No one has
something like that.
Look at that thing.
A frog.
Good Lord!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good.
Wow!
Well, how about the back?
Ooh. [ Laughs ]
Oh, yeah!
Oh, my gosh.
Let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Some lucky person is going to go
home in that sweater.
Everyone, look
at your seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
257!
♪♪
Come on down!
You're going the long way?
Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
Welcome!
Go over that way.
Nice to see you!
Oh, yeah. Hi, welcome.
How are you?
I love that you're three seats
from that way.
But you're one
of those people.
You're one of those people that
got up and made 12 people move.
[ Laughter ]
Hi, what is your name?
-I'm Xibo.
I'm from China.
-No way! Welcome!
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you.
-You see our show in China?
-Yeah like, back in China,
I started watching your show.
-I'm so excited.
I'm so happy that you're here.
I love the sweater you have on,
but I think --
-Should I put it on now?
-I think you should.
Yeah, I really do.
I really do.
I think this is --
it's a special --
Yes. Yes!
That's exactly right!
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Oh, it's so good.
It's so good.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my goodness!
Get her hair!
Get her hair.
Oh, look at --
Oh, my God, look at this!
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
[ Laughs ]
You make it look cute.
-Thank you.
-You make it look cute.
Let's give our winner
a round of applause.
Thank you for coming
all the way from China.
You can go up that side.
It's much faster, yeah.
Stick around --
we're playing "Password"
with Tyler Perry and
Michael Bublé after the break.
Come on back.
♪♪